I've just had a complaint from a couple
called down and Ella
they said the I hard sold them pressure
sold them first I pressure sold them to
come to the crash course then I pressure
sold them to buy my training programs
then the pressure sold them to go and
take action to get some property deals
there the pressure sold them to keep
going to become property millionaires
now their property millionaires and this
is what they have to say about all my
hard selling so at what point did you
actually come down to the crash course
John the Academy what was the what was
that what was that Jimmy like not that
long ago wasn't it was November yeah the
tail end of November last year so yeah
we came down to the crash course we
actually said this but we said that we
wouldn't be invested in driver training
because we've been to train him before
and we didn't feel it was for us but
when we were there we just we thought
that that it's actually a no-brainer
because if we could do what we've done
just by watching your YouTube videos
what could we do use in all these other
strategies yeah we thought we'd be nosy
when we and see what's going on we were
straight in the back we just signed
straight up Jimmy Hollister and signed
up straight away so you you were on the
receiving end of the pressure selling
like what can we do now before before
even got no actually Alice they even
said to us do you know what I'm not
gonna start with you if you're gonna do
it you're gonna do it if not then no cuz
we actually went to him said we want can
we have a work can we have a chat we
want to we want to talk to you about the
Academy because the the what we got just
from the crash course and from the
YouTube videos was enough for us to make
money wasn't it refinance in that first
house and if you can do that with no
support what can you do with support say
it made sense for you and you've been
doing business with a lot of a caddy
members yeah yeah and jayvees other
thing that we want to do and we've we've
actually done a deal with you haven't we
yeah with the with the money and the
lease option on the land yeah we've got
several of the Academy members that have
the message us constantly you know what
have you got coming up now anything
we can get involved in which is
incredible isn't it what first you were
kind of you know wanting to invest your
money into deals and people coming to
you with deals and then you were looking
at them and seeing them if it might work
for you but now it's getting to a point
where by you've got lots of deals and
you've got people coming to you wanting
to invest in the deals which is just a
really good season to be in it is yeah
and it wasn't really even intentional
was it well at that post that you put up
for the commercial/residential we just
posted something on social media about
the deal that we'd done already and from
that post we just had this influx of
people wanting to invest of us so we've
created investor list about you drive
you are very active on Facebook I mean
especially you a you Darren I see you
posting a lot of really positive stuff
and also when whenever there's
negativity going on I know that it won't
be say negative stuff he'll be shooting
down all the negative people but but you
can because you've you've done it you've
got the right yeah yeah if you can if
you've walked the walk then why not and
I think that's really important as well
and that's obviously come across well
because people message us a lot you know
to say you know let's do this let's do
that and even people who come in to us
now with their own deals saying we're
not quite sure what to do with this can
you help us and this is like eight
months after the crash course yeah so
yeah not sure what where we're gonna be
in five years time but so that's down
Ella folks every single week we have
winners on a Wednesday down and there
are gonna be this week's winners on the
winds down Wednesday if you want to be
shot in my living room you want to be
interviewed about property you want to
talk about how you become financially
free become a property millionaire that
you are gonna have to sell yourself sell
yourself sell yourself with your dreams
I'll set you on my course you can click
the link in the description pay a pound
and for seven days you can go through
the property investors crash course 95
pound a month you can have coaching you
have one-on-one mentoring I'll show you
on that be gonna say
sell yourself on why you've got to do
this and hopefully I'll see you in my
living room real soon for a winners on a
Wednesday comment below let me know when
you're gonna be on winners on a
Wednesday smash the like button
subscribe turn the notification bell on
I'll see you on Wednesday
peace